[Music]
how are you handling the pandemic listen
man i hunkered down with my whole family
about five months ago the only thing
that went wrong is somebody took my
cookies there's like 15 people in my
house i went to go get them cookies and
they weren't there
i knew my sister got it and i it was
four in the morning i walked in with the
light on my phone
literally like this and she would sleep
with her mouth open and i put the light
in
and i saw remnants of the cookie okay so
here's what we learned
jamie's house is where you want to hang
out there's cookies
hoverboards and lots and lots of music
[Music]
my 11 year old who now knows how to play
the piano so well she actually plays my
songs
while i sing to him
[Music]
she says dad i'm going on tour with you
so i'm blessed man
we are all blessed jamie's also got the
perfect thing to watch for movie night
with his crew
his new netflix sci-fi project power
co-starring
joseph gordon levitt it premieres next
week what do you need
you still got the pills up it's about
power it's about a drug on the street
where you take it
and you get five minutes of super power
but i'm
i'm a police officer undercover trying
to find out who's pushing this
but the best thing that's happened to
jamie lately the emmy nomination for the
live performance of good times
his daughter corrine was part of the
cast corrine how excited as a father
like what did you have to have a moment
you know how this business is and how
people struggle with rearing their kids
in this in this sort of tumultuous visit
so when you see your kid got a head on
our shoulders and now to be rewarded
uh with the emmy is just absolutely
[Music]
fantastic